-On our last show before break,
we did a bit with Addison Rae
where she taught me
eight viral TikTok dances.
Now, we recognize that
the creators of those dances
deserve to have
their own spotlight.
So right now some of
the creators will join me
to talk about
how their dance went viral
and then perform
the dance themselves.
Up first, we've got
Mya Nicole Johnson
and Chris Cotter,
who created the viral dance
to Cardi B's "Up."
Hey, Mya. Hey, Chris.
-Hi.
-Hello.
-Thanks for coming on
"The Tonight Show"
all the way from Houston.
-Thank you for having us.
-Please.
How long have you guys
known each other?
-It's been about --
It's gonna be two years.
-What is it like to choreograph
these dances together as a team?
-It's really fun, especially
when we're both really creative.
So when we put our dances
together,
it just makes it even better.
-And you came up with the dance
to "Up" by Cardi B.
What made you go with "Up"?
-So, basically, we already knew
that we were linking up
prior to the video.
And so we already knew
that Cardi B had just came out
with a new song called "Up"
and it was going viral.
Everyone was, like,
listening to the song.
So we knew that if we were to
make, like, a challenge to it,
it had potential of going viral.
-Now, Cardi B herself
even reposted it.
How great was that
when you saw what she did?
-That was really exciting.
She posted our video two times
on her Instagram
and then one time on TikTok.
So yeah, that was
a great experience.
-I love it. Alright.
You're gonna perform your "Up"
dance for us right now.
Whenever you guys are ready,
take it away.
Thank you for being here.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
See, that's how you do it.
That's what I'm talking about.
Mya Nicole Johnson
and Chris Cotter.
Check them out on TikTok
@theemyanicole and @cchrvs.
Thank you guys so much
for coming on.
-Thank you so much.
-Next, we have the creator
of the Corvette Corvette dance,
Dorian Scott,
a.k.a. Yvnggprince Dorian.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi. How are you?
-I'm doing good, buddy.
Thank you so much
for being here.
I appreciate it.
Tell us a little bit
about yourself.
I know -- Are you from Philly?
-Yes. I'm from
North Philadelphia.
Actually born and raised,
and my mom
is always telling me
to put school first,
so I want to let y'all know
that I'm a freshman
at the University of Delaware,
studying visual communications.
But I also a model
and can dance.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
School first.
I agree. Your mom's right.
You created
the Corvette Corvette dance,
which is to the song
"Adderall (Corvette Corvette)"
by Popp Hunna.
Now, have you been dancing
for a long time?
-Yes, honestly,
I've been dancing
since before I can remember.
But I started off as a gymnast.
I finished third in a region
from New York to Virginia.
And then I started
focusing more on my dance.
And fast-forward to TikTok,
I'm making a lot
of dance videos on there.
And I used to get like
500,000 views, a million.
So the artists
actually hit me up
and asked me
to dance to their song
and make it a challenge.
-Now, where do you go from here?
What do you hope to be doing
in the next few years?
-So I want to be an all-around
performer, entertainer.
Will Smith and Kevin Hart,
they're like my inspirations.
I love their journey, and one of
my dream roles would be to play
a live-action version
of Miles Morales as Spider-Man.
-Spider-Man?
-Yeah.
I told you I was a gymnast,
so you know
I got the moves and stuff.
And I think I think I look
kind of good in tights.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, there's your next
Spider-Man right there.
Now you're going to perform
the Corvette Corvette dance
for all of us.
Please, whenever you're ready,
buddy,
and thank you again, Dorian.
♪♪
Yo, come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how you do it
right there!
You can see more
from Dorian on TikTok.
His handle is @yvnggprince.
Thank you so much
for being here, bud.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Up next, he created
the Laffy Taffy Remix
and she came up with the dance.
Here are Fly Boy Fu and Indii.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi!
-Hello. How are you?
-Look at you.
Good to see you guys.
Fu, you made this remix
about 10 years ago,
and now it became
huge on TikTok.
How did you find out that
it had gotten so popular?
-I was on social media
a while back, like,
before my parents
had passed away.
And I heard A-DuB, the producer
here, put this beat out.
And he was like, "I need lyrics
for this, this beat."
And I liked the beat.
It was really, really catchy.
So I went in the studio,
in my parents' studio,
and then I just closed my eyes
and I started to freestyle.
And that was the first take.
I just sent it over to him.
-One take.
-And he made the track.
-Wow!
And, Indii, you came up
with the dance.
Did you know it was
going to go viral
or you're just hoping
and you're just like,
"I'm just gonna try this"?
-I made the dance just because,
and then two years later,
look, it's on TikTok.
It's viral. I'm like --
It's shocking, because, like,
I wasn't even expecting it
to go viral.
-How long does it take you
to come up with a dance?
-Like about five minutes.
I had made it on the bus
because I went to school,
and then when I got home,
I recorded the dance
and posted it.
-You say you made it on the bus?
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh.
That's fantastic.
I want to see the dance
if you don't mine.
Ladies and gentlemen,
here's Indii performing
"Laffy Taffy Remix" by Fu.
Take it away.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Check out Fly Boy Fu and Indii
on TikTok
@flyboyfu and @17slumz.
Thank you again
for being here, you guys.
I really appreciate it.
-Thank you for having us.
-Good luck with whatever
you do next.
Next up are the creators
of the Blinding Lights dance,
Greg Dahl, Adam Snyder,
and Nate Nale.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hello, guys.
-How are you doing?
-Nice to see you.
Now, you all share
the TikTok handle @macdaddyz.
How do you all know each other?
-So, actually,
first and foremost,
thanks for having us on.
We really appreciate it.
But to the question,
we're actually
roommates for the past two years
at Immaculata University
in Pennsylvania.
But that's kind of how
the whole friendship started
and the account really
was created through that.
-Now, how did the Blinding
Lights dance come to be?
'Cause I heard it started with
the foot move,
which is basically
about as far as I can go.
But what is the story
behind the whole deal?
-Yeah.
So I've actually been like
a huge fan
of The Weeknd for a while.
And when that song first came
out, I was listening to it
all the time,
playing it at school.
And just one night,
we were dancing to it.
And the foot move, actually,
that was like
our go-to dance back then.
So we put that in there and we
added some hand movements,
and it just kind of went
together perfectly.
-You're going to perform
the Blinding Lights dance
for us now on
"The Tonight Show."
Are you guys ready?
-Oh, we're ready.
-Go for it whenever.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go.
-Thank you so much.
-Yeah, thanks for having us.
-You can follow Greg, Adam,
and Nate on TikTok.
Their handle is @macdaddyz.
Thanks for coming on the show,
guys.
And finally, please say hello to
the creator of the Savage dance,
Keara Wilson, a.k.a. Queen Keke!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello, everyone.
-Hi, Keara.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
-Now, for over a year,
everyone on TikTok
has been doing your dance
to Megan Thee Stallion's song
"Savage."
Can you take me back to the day
that you created it?
Like, what led up to
you posting it?
-Absolutely.
I just had moved to Texas
from Ohio to be with my sister.
So, she was about
to have her baby.
At that time, I just had
graduated high school
and I didn't know what I wanted
to do with my life.
So basically,
I needed an outlet to destress.
So I downloaded TikTok.
I've been dancing for 10 years.
And I seen that people were
doing a bunch of dances
on TikTok,
so I wanted to try it too.
So I made one up, you know?
And it took me about 30 minutes
to choreograph
because I kept changing
the ending.
Originally the ending
was really hard.
But I'm actually glad
I didn't change it.
-I think the whole
thing is hard.
Can you show me
what was the hard ending?
Could you show me
what that was like?
-Yeah.
♪♪
-That's what I'm talking about.
That's my favorite part.
That is so great.
What is it like to be able
to see your dance catch on
and become viral?
-I never expected to it blow up
like it did.
I just did it for fun, honestly.
Then I just kept seeing it grow.
Celebrities were doing it.
Little kids were doing it.
It was the best.
But I would have to say,
seeing my dance bring joy
to people throughout quarantine
was definitely the best part.
-Yeah. We love it too,
and I'm so happy
that you came on the show.
I also want to say
congratulations are in order.
You're engaged.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah! That's what
I'm talking about.
Now, how much pressure
is on your fiancé now?
-Oh, my gosh, a lot
because I'm going to
make up some cool dances,
and he can't really dance.
[ Laughter ]
He has rhythm.
-Good luck, buddy!
-He has rhythm.
[ Laughter ]
-It's gonna be fun.
Everyone's gonna look forward
to that.
Thank you so much
for coming on our show.
Keara Wilson.
Follow her on TikTok
@keke.janajah right there.
Thank you so much for coming on.
Our thanks to all the creators
for joining me tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much
for being here. Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Milo Ventimiglia, everyone.
Come on back.
I can't do -- I can't do --
I can't even do that.
I'll do that.
♪♪